you
[Music]
this morning on the dish he helped
pioneer the development of California
cuisine then brought it thousands of
miles east to his hometown chef Zach
rule was born and raised in the
Cleveland area and while seemingly
destined to join a family business
became a chef instead he made his first
mark at the influential Michaels in
Santa Monica California and he thought
the blend of simple cooking techniques
and the freshest ingredients would be a
hit back home his first venues II
contemporary cuisine transformed the
local dining scene and led to his
current collection of eight Cleveland
area restaurants a cruel good morning
welcome to the dish
great pian here tell us about this
really great table okay here we go we've
got a cassoulet stuffed the oysters a
squash salad pommes frites
lemon polenta cake and we're gonna wash
it down with a barrel aged bourbon man
hat don't mind if I do may as well start
the morning off exactly know when you
got into cooking it was a little
different route you were actually in
business school and I would say an act
of defiance against your father got you
huh I was at the Wharton School of
Finance I was supposed to take over my
dad's business which was what he was a
manufacturer's rep I was the only Son
uh-huh resistors so I was being groomed
for that business and there was a kid
down the hall that had a hot a toaster
oven I had a hot plate and we just
started cooking that's how I spent my
freshman year at the University of
Pennsylvania and it had a dairy dad take
it when you said I'm not well I came
home after a semester and said I don't
think I want the business how did he
take it well he was sort of a guess and
then he said what are you gonna do say I
want to become a chef well that didn't
go over very well either back in 1972
nice upper middle-class Jewish kids from
Shaker Heights Ohio weren't becoming
chefs going to the family business or
lawyers did that stay with you as you
moved we talked about Michaels and then
obviously bring in cuisine back to
Cleveland did that always stay with you
of course I was chasing this ghost and
the ghost was my father and
and you know I wanted to prove to him
that I was gonna make it and I was gonna
succeed and that I was gonna do it at
the top level that I could yeah so your
drive was fired by that all along well
you know I probably am a Type A all
right but you know there was that
impetus behind me of course mm-hmm
did he ever have the moment of pride in
what you were doing oh yeah oh yeah I
mean unfortunately he didn't get to see
it but he knew before he died that it
was going to work he knew what I was
going to do yeah so that must have been
satisfying that that was great but you
know fortunately my mother lived to age
95 so she saw almost every restaurant
that I opened up you know Michael
Michaels in Santa Monica and the idea of
California cuisine back then when you
went there this was 1980 and you know
the the restaurant scene in the United
States wasn't it wasn't what it is now
so there were people flocking people
chefs that were flocking from all over
the world to Southern California because
there was a food revolution going on out
there all due respect to New York but
the food revolution at that point was
going out in Southern California and I
was fortunate at the age of 27 to be
right in the middle of it what made you
bring it back to Cleveland well I wanted
to settle up with my father yeah so I
had a two-year plan to go back there and
just stay there save all my money and
then go back to Southern California and
open up a restaurant in Santa Barbara
this was 1982 so I was supposed to be
believing in 1984 so I'm slightly behind
[Laughter]
well I realized that I had built up this
goodwill yeah and circumstances were
such that my dad got sick and I wasn't
just gonna leave well I'm gonna have you
sign our dish and as I do I'll ask you
if you could have this meal with anyone
pastor price
who would it be would be my father
definitely around the rock it would be a
round of golf and then dinner afterwards
yeah fantastic well chefs a cruel thank
you so very much for morons a cruel and
the dish you can head to our website at
CBS this morning calm